[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
20 strong chess players from nine
Federation's compete in st. Louis
u.s. chess champs calm presents the
third annual winter chess classic hello
and welcome back to our live coverage of
the winter chats classic it's always
we're your hosts my name is Caleb Denby
I'm joined by the wonderful Sabina
Voyager thank you
today is round seven of the action in
the limits yeah two thirds of the
tournament down just this lot in these
last three games to get through and who
do you who are your picks
to win at all I don't know I haven't
thought about it for sure Renaud Jim
above has done really great in in this
tournament so far he's the leader of the
a group but you know there's some quite
some people training him yes absolutely
Geoffrey Zhang same setting Daniel nerd
it's skiing all hoping to catch up to
the leaders there oh sure and it's not
gonna be a tough it's not going to be
something very easy plus Renaud my Bible
is playing against m7 today so yes
perhaps a chance for Sam why don't we
actually check out our standings in the
a group we have Rinna Jim abaya with an
incredible four and a half points out of
six that's plus three already in this
event and I mean I was looking through
his games before the show started I
don't think he's been worse in six games
I don't think he's had a worse like even
slightly worse position he's just
playing good consistent solid chess for
sure and he does have a pretty good
balance of his time so I think that's
just something else very good and I
really like the fact that after every
round I see him downstairs with his
opponent trying to go over the game
which is really nice cuz that's how you
started getting better you know yeah
just very good form by
Jeffrey Zhang actually was defeated
yesterday by the leader and what was an
incredibly complicated game but he'll be
looking to make some points back up
today for Jeffrey the highest rated
player in the a group daniel narada ski
in sam seven of course also both on
three and a half points just one point
behind Rinat again now is the time if
you're there if they're gonna catch the
leader they have to start winning some
games for sure Grigory oprand sethu and
Victor Erdos all on three out of six and
Havana's Qaboos Ian
Alexis tirana and vara Cobian round out
the a group and why don't you check out
what's going on in the B group the B
group actually has two leaders at the
moment that is Sergey Azeroth and Alexis
Sorokin who are actually playing each
other which is really nice that'll be an
exciting one to look out for today
the two leaders facing off here in round
six Mela Cotchin federico perez Ponza
emilio cordova and tigran harder to
naeun are all on three and a half points
out of six
yeah and harder to nyan yesterday got
really lucky he's upon and just blunder
the rock the young Christopher you just
unexplainable just drop the rook and
must have been really tough so stick
around guys got his life yesterday and
just everyday every good tournament has
a couple of rounds course you caught a
lucky break but definitely a six players
very much in contention to take home the
first-place prize here in the B group
everything is so possible and why don't
we check out the format for this
tournament and see what's going on there
we have 210 player around Robins course
that's the a group and the B group the
time control for the event is 90 minutes
for 40 moves and then 30 minutes are
added on for the remainder of the game
there's also a 30 second increment
starting on move one and in addition to
that there is a draw rule in effects so
the players are not allowed to agree to
a draw until black makes this 30th move
and the schedule for the events is 1:00
p.m. every day for the rounds barring
that final day Monday November 8th just
a couple days away now the ground will
be starting two hours early as will our
show so be sure to tune in at 1:30 on
Monday for our show and as always 3:30
p.m. for today and tomorrow
mm-hm and with that in mind we'd like to
thank you guys for joining us here on
YouTube I see a lot of you in the chat
already Friar Tuck all the way coming in
from New Zealand hi on Jiao is asking us
for our picks what I think Rinat govt of
is the the you know the likely pick for
the a group and in the moment yet for
the moment yes but I see a lot of these
younger American players who can catch
up so what is just you me do they say
you know of course I mean I would root
for one of the three Daniel Nutter
discus m7 or or Jefferies show and God
knows yeah each one of them but all
three kind of part of this this next
generation yeah super strong American
chess players we don't definitely be on
the lookout for them if you want to get
involved on Twitter as well can use the
hashtag winter chess Classic and as
always you can follow the games for
yourself on us chess champs calm to see
what's going on there
thank you pick your favorite games
follow along with the engine see if
we're spouting nonsense or what we're
saying is actually true and get involved
that way
well Sabina I think that's about it why
don't we check out the pairings in the a
group we have Daniel married Itsuki who
has already drawn his game against Fe
vara Cobian is paired against Grigory
Oberon the leader Renaud Jim abaya faces
one of those second place people Sam
setting Victor Erdos is against Jeffrey
Zhang and in our key matchup of the game
day we're actually going to be looking
at this game between Alexis tirana and
Havana's kuboos Ian there's some very
interesting developments that have
already taken place
and we can see on the screen Cambodian
that's not seem very happy I can't say
that I feel so bad I keep saying oh no
there's obviously some more expressive
chess players than others yeah that's
true yeah I think I'll chess players
show it in some way when they've got a
terrible position and they're suffering
a bit maybe maybe a little bit yeah some
some people have a better way of not
showing it but I believe most of us do
in a way or another so if you stand
study facial expressions of chess
players for sure you would not be sorry
you would have a lot to to try to guess
from that but so so what's going on here
let's look at the position I mean it's
just seems like whites should be really
close to winning the whites nice move
was f5 so f6 of course is almost an
unstoppable threat and of course the
only way to do that is to actually take
on f5 which I believe that just happened
and the problem that black has is the
lack of space okay they also had a pond
down now white just gave it back by
playing a5 but this point is going to be
falling and let's just look at black's
pawn structure i should have made it
with raster it's disastrous
yes I mean no every single pawn is an
island and that's something you try to
avoid I mean look at those pawns six
pawns weak
yeah know that there's there's no way
that black can hold all of us together I
think maybe just like Knight g3 from
white it's very simple it attacks both
of those weak bonds and probably both
will fall for sure they will fall and
it's definitely very unpleasant for
black they don't have space their bishop
in g7 is also restricted by their own
pawn it never got to be really opened
the night in f8 is not doing so great
maybe black could try some way to
improve the position of an
but even if you get with the Knight to
e5 is not going to be enough really
because that's definitely not the key is
so weak and especially once this H pawn
falls you'll see those those Rick's for
white on h1 and g1 kind of you know that
they seem worse than your ex on the
e-file but once that H pawn falls and
white starts pushing the H and G pawn
yeah there will be perfectly placed to
attack the way for sure for sure I mean
those are I think they're really crazy
place there's ideas with g6 also for
white and try just to open up the G file
and if you play F 610 your bishop will
be completely closed oh and I believe
Alexis dress is actually Knight f6 and
actually maybe I like it better a little
bit Knight f6 instead of 93 yeah my
feeling was Knight of six looks very
attractive but I didn't really want to
give like even a chance to trade off
such a horrible Bishop but if it opens
the G file it's honestly it's just worth
it yeah yeah definitely if that file
gets open it's going to be really bad
and I'm anticipating a resignation very
soon from black not much to be the same
no I mean you know you don't want to
give the bishop because that's the only
protecting piece that you have so if you
do give it up then you can capture we
have ideas the Queen to come over or on
g2 going for g7 you will not be safe or
even g5 you know there are so many
places white screen can come to and you
really have no contra plate
no way to attack white skin wasting is
really safe and unfortunately we've been
looking very good for Alexei well why
don't we check out what's going on with
the B group pairings and I think we
might also actually have a result there
yes and that resultant being actually
have two results there I think we just
had a result drawn between Sorokin and
Sergei Zharkov and I'm hoping we can get
one of the players down here interviews
definitely I think we're we're it's a
work in progress yes
course for all of our parents we do see
those two results there Alexis Sorokin
one of the leaders has drawn the other
leader Sergey azarov's so they both
maintain their position for the day at
the top of the pack but it does leave
the door open for one of those other
myriad of players to try to catch up
yeah
so who's it going to be in the B group
Justin wing is playing a Sergei Arenberg
Emilio Cordova is playing L Shawn
Marathi Abadi and Emilio is one of those
players within striking distance
Christopher you has actually already
drawn his game against Melek Cotchin and
Federico Perez poncy is playing Tigran
horror trillion in our key matchup of
the day of course both Federico and
Tigran have the ability to catch the
leaders with a win today so if that game
is decisive there will be a third person
joining the top of the leaderboard
that's going to be interesting to see
you and we actually have the position
the current position and we can see the
players battling it for trying to catch
the leaders this is the current position
that we have what do you think I really
like white uh yeah White has this very
nice central space advantage with this
this pawn on e5 the bishops very very
active and most importantly this night
on a 2 is is not ideally placed in it
might come under fire pretty soon it's a
trap I do want to say though I believe
we do have Alexei Serkan here in for an
interview so I will step out of the the
chair for a moment okay get in here to
talk about his tournament sounds great
all right so this is the current
position that we have in the game Paris
Monza against harutunian so rook c8 was
played on white immediately traded the
rugs I'm anticipating a real capture
which just happened and now black is
going to fight to try to find a way to
escape with this knife from a two it's
going to be very very tough oh not quite
sure how exactly we will trap it but
it's trapped for the moment so nothing
to be worried about and I'm joined here
by Alexa rockin who just drew his game
and maintained his lead in the big group
how do you feel being in this tournament
so far your professor I need one point
more to get okay
you played you had a pretty good
tournament we were hoping to get you
here talk to us earlier but
unfortunately I finished in five yes you
play the second game like yeah did you
go today for thinking that you want to
try to make a draw or what was your
mindset going into today's rounds I
didn't expect okay
Brooksie one is pretty pretty typical
right so in this position it should be
seven and this is pretty pretty logical
took took and a three to five you play
this route to avoid Bishop Bishop before
yeah right
and usually black does not go for Queen
takes d5 oftentimes I think they go for
for the capture with the pawn like yes
right Bishop c5 castle white is slightly
but Quinta is day five it's a new new
idea I think problem maybe not too new
and now you're threatening to taking c7
so c5 seems kind of obvious and then
you're going into this position which
seems pretty I have some chances to win
this position at least I cannot yeah I
mean yes so you're going into the game
okay draw it's at least a draw yeah of
course
so and here Bishop e5 I mean usually
white because of the the way you have
the pieces development you should have a
very tiny advantage I think what's
minimal probably and then you try your
best but if the opponent gets a good
placement of the pieces I think it's do
you think there was any moment where you
could have tried to nothing okay Bishop
takes this is yeah Bishop takes h7 kind
of force you're getting the poem but
then you kind of have to give it up very
soon 93 check and what did you plan
against this move rook c1 maybe look see
637 group Shae to be 5 Farouk c8 can't
you just say that
take care
maybe Oh
93 is coming next right king here I do
maybe vitamin doesn't zoom doesn't seem
so safe or black I think I prefer white
in this position but Knight takes a four
okay you see he messes up your bone
structure I think because of these free
points on f1 and looks like we have a
result in our key match of the day GABA
lion has just resigned against Serrano
so we might have Serrano coming joining
us a little bit later today that was an
interesting game in the in the group yes
well we haven't had you down here for an
interview we wanted to hear your
thoughts about being here in San Luis is
this have you have you played in spring
yes and I also four out of seven and
I was one point more in last two games
but I lost two games you have to keep
your you have to keep your calm you know
in the next next next two rounds and
tell us where do you live you went to
Texas second University how do you like
it there it's good I used to live there
actually for three years so it's yeah
it's it's it's an interesting place to
live do you do like being in the United
States yes yes good that's good we're
we're happy to have you here thanks for
for joining us today and we should be
luck in there are mainly two rounds all
right so we we just finished our
interview with Alexei Sorokin and Alex
Lisa Rana will be joining us in just a
moment I think let us just pull up the
game and just look at the final position
so it seems like the last moment we were
looking at night of six in this position
black tried to defend a little bit with
96 and of course white is not going for
the rook that's the least to expect in
this position definitely want to go for
the mate Quincy one very beautiful and
after night of for look f1 black
resigned there's no way to defend that
pawn and Alexis around I just joined me
here welcome and congratulations really
nice game today how do you feel part of
it for me so so you're coming you're
coming back I mean the tournament is
very long I mean now only two more
rounds after today so tell us about the
opening did you expect yeah of course
all the ways under neither know what
what was the moment where you're here he
played after 95 he played bit Knight
takes d5 now he played Bishop differ
that's what she's mean but Bishop defy
his more famous wolf and more strong
okay yes but this is I think why this
white supposed to be a little bit better
very soon and I wasn't sure where he yes
so I I didn't about rook shade so maybe
rook shade this is not Jericho no so
black black usually placed knight Knight
b6 can be fun night to be take 65 Bishop
a5 and here long - yes so he tried to
change something I mean at some point
you have to make some changes it's okay
so here you are out of your out the fury
but you're still believe is that he also
know he plays fast but it was maybe it
was okay
so King b1 seems very natural try to get
out from the C file just making sure and
you have to finish your development but
g4 is definitely something that's coming
here I mean h5 doesn't seem to be really
helping Queen c7 and c4 and in this
position were you ever worried that
black was going to be able to play some
d 5 at some point I think that's what he
should try to do now
okay doesn't seem so good right yes but
maybe he should play in this position
this is because I have a lot of if you
place I don't see what instead of but
it's not so easy if here before if I
just take and yeah it's a free point I
think you just take it if he goes to if
she goes castles so just didn't g4
directly into very dangerous position so
can black ever just decide to go maybe
maybe I can play for edge for first and
lemon ginger Fergus okay so maybe he can
just move his rook to b8 and try to go
for b5 and then maybe look Steve on it
good okay
that's where your lighting b3 is is
pretty good yes because you are you're
just stopping Queen a5 the Queen cannot
be improved maybe an a5 also maybe you
just think so maybe ideas will
appreciate and
and then you just got had a really great
attack here after g4 we did not okay
trying some a5 not so easy find what to
do this black so position already bad
but yeah but this move it's not so clear
what what she was trying to do I think
okay
what do you think about maybe just going
would you still go green [ __ ] - okay and
then a four knob do you can take the
closet I don't thinks seems to be very
difficult maybe this Queen does not
belong in c7 anymore I should maybe move
it here have some ideas like that's at
some point oh maybe I don't know I'm not
that you fart there so I just try to
guess so
no it's too much interesting but okay
idea that didn't seem and then it seemed
kind of effortless for you from here on
if I play plants very natural move yeah
yeah okay f4 and yeah I just go nicely
one method to night before and I just
really sore so easy game yeah this night
can be improved that way and then
there's no plan for black this is the
big problem because you never get god b5
he never got to attack you on the king
and then do enough to Russia
okay yeah an Isis tree okay also so okay
night before but boom okay maybe
hereafter queen d1 him should take you
just take your Bishop probably take you
the Queen right yes what you can some
Bishop g5 first maybe take on the six
maybe Bishop g5 yes but so to try to
take take and up enough maybe but I see
I can see that you want to take these
pawns you're not scared a lot of people
are very scared to go take you know
pawns on the other side of the board
where they open your king but you took
the a four point you didn't so I also
saw things did can do one go in take
Bishop taken before and take on the full
but yeah but he and you're letting he
maybe get the SPECIAL poppin it's a good
compensation my girls are here slightly
worse but yeah she has just some Condor
played so Queen do you want very
interesting and like move you're saying
okay take my light square Bishop I don't
care so much about that one
I think this bishops probably better to
keep a little bit longer and then you
got that very beautiful finish there
Isola Bishop d3 one moment
I saw that here he you should play it
before judges resigned so we'd be five
over here yes can you take it or what
did you plan to do after before I
thought if if I take C take before he
has rook takes c3 c5
yeah
dangerous position a metaphor right so I
know okay take on b5 maybe but okay if I
played Bishop days before he played he
takes before important move yes no no no
okay maybe I already you have to take
your time first before fish I saw that
I'll play g5 and here he should play and
here just take a pony's missed night
uh-huh 95 and 97 a green take a 5f 495
and Bishop before debate about its
playable yes yeah so he it seemed like
he he didn't really find the right
moment to break into the position and
then your play was was really just g5
yeah yeah we saw this final part we were
discussing this final part it's kind of
easy for you now you just push the F
pawn and the position of blacks position
collapses thank you so much for joining
us and going into into your thoughts for
today's game two more rounds how are
your feelings about the last two rounds
yes after the win today
it sounds good well thank you so much
for joining us and I wish you good luck
in the last two rounds thank you
alright so that was Alexis run after a
very beautiful win against caboose Ian
of hannes and we should go check this
game out between Victor Erdos and
Geoffrey Zhang I think this is a very
interesting position that we can try to
evaluate as
caleb is getting ready to join me back
into the show so Wow look at this
position Black has I think a winning a
winning position what do you think Caleb
well let's see I'm counting the pawns
one all right Black has more pawns black
has more clones but most importantly the
white king is is kind of getting rekt
here it's very tough this nice is close
by and let's not forget about you know
the Queen and the rook right yeah wait a
second yeah this is counting the pawn
yeah I know you forgot about the major
pieces
okay so Queen and Eric for two rooks and
Bishop who so I guess we can just say
queen for rook and Bishop and the pond
and this should be really amazing for
for Geoffrey if he wins this game and
he's really close to winning he just
played actually Queen f6 in this
position we are going to see him join
well catch up with the leader for the
moment that game is still going on yeah
of course that we not not looking like
he's in too much danger actually yet
today yeah you might keep his lead by
half point but Geoffrey being a very
professional you know it's tough to keep
these 2,700 players down they lose one
game and what they do is they come back
and they win the next three yeah I mean
they don't give up there's no moment
where they would say oh no I lost how
terrible I played I have no more chances
no not at all they are really determined
to come back in the tournament and even
if they might say some negative things
those are just temporary I've done it
myself you are really focused and back
into the game in media today definitely
Geoffrey wants to win this tournament I
am sure no doubt about it he wants that
for sure and he has the material
advantage he has the right position
attack
white so this could be a really good
come like an amazing comeback for
Jeffrey and we you know yeah doesn't
stop it'll certainly make things more
interesting these past two two rounds if
Renaud is under a little bit of pressure
of course to win some games to keep that
leading yeah I mean one point is not as
much considering there's three more
rounds right so you have one point
difference but you still have to
maintain that if you know if you lose
one game then someone can catch up with
you so you really want to try to
continue playing good chess scores and
always be on the look for the
competitors expecting Jeffrey to be able
to pull this one out why don't we
actually take a look at our key matchup
in B I don't believe these actually no
we did not do that
we of course have Federico Ponza against
Tigran roots Union Union of course both
of these players just a half point out
of the lead going into today and none of
the leaders have officially drawn in the
B group if this game is decisive there
will be someone joining those leaders
for the half points out of seven and so
why don't we see what's going on over
over the board here okay so this is a
current position that we have and a few
changes have happened since we last look
at the position it's actually happened
as I was getting ready to start the
interviews and they think in this
position a black is still a little bit
worse but he was able to escape with his
knight I mean yeah
White's a very powerful Bishop and this
a six pawn looks backwards but black
speakers have gotten active this Knight
has improved I mean if we go back into
this position right where the knight was
back in a two and it looked like there's
no way this Knight was going to to get
active in any way it seems like after a
few moves black was able to bring it to
d3 how did that happen Quincy for you
just puts it on and see one I suppose
Wow okay I did not think of that idea of
course we didn't have that
much time to discuss it this game but
night to see one whoa okay that's that's
a very nice that's a very nice come back
into the game you don't often use the
the eighth-ranked to know to transfer
your pieces on the good outposts yeah
but this is a very nice idea Queen c4 in
nineteen one and now that Knight comes
back into the game and rotate one
putting pressure on e6 and black
responds with Queen to e4 let's get rid
of that arrow we do not need it at this
point it's tough
so can white take on a six it doesn't
look very good to me honestly I I do not
believe what can capture here I'm
anticipating shadow check and there's
also some a pawn business to look out
for but I'm not sure that we cannot we
cannot capture it just yet maybe maybe a
like should have just capture the e pawn
instead yeah and Geoffrey shame is
officially over he has won his game
against Victor Erdos in the a group so
he moves to a score of four and a half
out of seven for the moment tied with
Rena Juma buyeth of course Ranaut's game
has not finished yet so if we not
manages even just to draw he keeps keeps
the lead for today the camera on that
game a little bit yes maybe we'll be
able to get Geoffrey down here actually
in just a few minutes for an interview
yeah it'll be interesting to to get his
thoughts on that psychology aspect of it
I've coming from from losing a game to
coming back winning with the black
pieces and in the next round it's very
impressive stuff
and we are still looking at this game a
little bit came Quinta sure I think so I
think this night of four would have been
my fears I'm hanging for look now looks
dangerous looks a little bit dangerous
because now if you
oh but maybe you can play f3 maybe it's
not as dangerous as I was hoping
I may be maybe black could just take on
e5 after it takes a 6 yeah I'm not sure
instead of mercy lunch oh oh okay yeah
that takes e5 pawn for a part if there's
no phone off for white yeah that should
work and now we might bring the Knight
to c4 and I think things look ok for
black mm-hmm
so uh Federico actually chose Queen III
in the game I think rather than there
yeah
you went for Queen III so he was like no
I don't I don't want to give up my
central pawn for this backwards pawn
which anyways yes it's a long-term
weakness he offers up this Queen's right
hoping to simplify a bit but I do
believe we have Geoffrey Zhang here and
for another interview so it's great
that's my chair once again
alright so Queen III in this position
and Wow
well obviously the Queen trade would not
be such a great idea thing for black
because this Knight once again will find
itself kind of trapped in White's
territory at least temporary and that
pawn is still a weakness but maybe maybe
it's fine if we do not trade the Queen's
in this position I don't know we need
three very interesting but I have
Geoffrey Zhang joining me
after a very beautiful wing today and I
come back after a tough loss yesterday
congratulations Jeffrey nice comeback
everyone here today wanted to hear your
thoughts about what did you do what do
you do after a tough loss how do you
come back into the you know the new day
focusing or
your goals and you know winning with
black pieces what do you need to do or
what did you do well I'm not really the
guy who gets too upset after losing
losses are inevitable so you just have
to figure out a way to move on and focus
on the next game
I totally agree with you I think it's
you know you I'm surprised to hear you
don't get upset I get very upset when I
lose of course I know it's a learning
experience but sometimes you just feel
like you're so mad at yourself for for
having missed miss things so you went
into today's game relaxed and ready to
just I mean not relaxed like ready to
for a fight exactly what do you was this
preparation the opening that you play
yeah I mean I prepared this b5 system
but I didn't really check it before the
game so okay
it's very wild and I wasn't sure if I
remember the line correctly so yeah this
is 95 maybe six
this is all normal so far and yeah Queen
d2 is kind of okay but nice the Queen d2
is popular idea to try to bring the
Queen via f4 g3 and harrassed yeah
Bishop h6 really right so that's why
black usually goes through the city with
this should be seven I was surprised
that he started with rib d1 because
usually they played queen of four mm-hmm
and we could get something similar like
Queen d7 Queen g3 g5 something similar
to the game where
I like to counsel long and it's a race
who gets first together other signs King
so he went for a noob t1 first and so
this was something that you had prepared
before no this is I'm not sure I'm not I
wasn't sure about this move order it was
a little bit surprised about when you
played g5 or giving giving out that
point of course and it's a very
beautiful idea opening up the G file but
yeah I'm not actually sure if this was
correct or not because there's an idea
let's say if you go back a few news yes
of course let's say there should be
seven Queen a for Queen d7 Queen g3g 5
and there's Knight g5 Bishop g5 Queens
you 597 there's a game like this but
here black is winning but compared to
the game he has rook on d1 cuz you're
gonna go for something now or maybe this
real quick yep was b5 many signs
yes so win the piece but I wasn't sure
about the version in the game because
with the real kind d1 here D funds
uh-huh so after after capturing
everything mm-hmm uh-huh
so you're thinking 97 yeah how do you
find like it's happened in the game all
right I can't take the night because d6
and my Kings o D 6 D just nothing very
fun ok so I had to take on d5
and now I thought this was critical if
whether or not he could take on c4 this
I wasn't sure and I have to root g8 now
I don't know where to move this we
probably have to protect d1 so maybe a
teenage fine and this was the critical
position let's say keeps the pressure
yeah I don't know I've either Queen six
or long Council I don't think I can take
on g2 because your Queen could be my
queen is hanging generates a good night
yeah this if matter for King f1 I think
the end game is because the Lucas
protect us at this good yeah I can take
when I try gonna be even material but
the end game looks good for the net on
each one is done with Bishop enjoys the
pair of bishops to sir
okay so maybe but Queen c6 instead was
interesting
now this is probably what he wasn't sure
about this at Florence seems to be the
only move to protect you too I mean the
good news is I don't think I can make a
discovery with my knife
for example night at 493 he can take on
c7 here
oh nice intermediate move cuz you cannot
go King f8 probably but if I take with
Queen Bishop f4 yeah yeah I'm just down
yeah this can I try can D let's see what
danger six rips you soon ah but I'm pin
so you just picks up the night yeah you
don't have four wait let's see so right
do it was too much like can I take any
six could be possible
you can also maybe taking on the eight
is very simple because it's a lot of
right now already nine eight six Bishop
h6 so much because they're still peeing
that's the problem otherwise you would
take g2 that's why I don't think Queen
c6 works because also he will get tempos
later like with 94 for example mmhmm
yeah just get the night out of the
hanging place yes in a better position
so here maybe long castles but I'm not
sure I believe because not only has
Bishop g5 closing the G file and
developing
I mean at some point maybe you'll be
able to push some h6 to chase that
Bishop away maybe yeah maybe like King
ba to prepare something that I have a
feeling that if he can get away with
this he'll be just better because
but for sure is a very complicated and
interesting position requires by some
analysis I think if you're going to the
game without having really seen these
ideas it's not really so easy for white
to the two decide to go for this
disappointing c4 so just go for a four
but now I think when I keep this pawn
and I still have this attack yeah seems
nice and now you just chase the night
away and you have the Queen d7 so he
doesn't come back her tempo and now it
doesn't seem like white can't get easily
an attack on your King exactly I thought
at this point it's very difficult so you
play he played f3 yeah it was launched
but that sometimes can be actually a
target - yeah I try to take advantage of
AG statistics but okay the critical was
bishops before I think is okay but after
c5 he needed to go to e2 with the point
being he wants to put it on g3 to block
the G from there's no tricks and I
wasn't sure what I have here because
probably he was afraid of 95 but after
Bishop d5 I'm not sure how good this is
for me
so I'm assuming you do not really want
the young king yeah I wasn't sure like I
mean this should be fine what's a knight
g3 decipher no one to make this
sacrifice it what about Age 5
yeah h1 is natural now either because my
King is also a little bit loose right so
yeah there's a lot of double attack
ideas Queen III Queen e2 to hit or maybe
Queen e5 also might allow some
sacrifices finally enough today maybe
not but yeah here Queenie 3 for example
okay I can't cover with Queen c7
so actually maybe queen maybe couldn't
you - I'm good
maybe Queenie - but then
that seems to me seems to me that's just
a check so if I move my queen then you
can go maybe we should be seven so I
wonder if we could just do the same
thing but but now the queen is you need
to maybe Bishop f4 will be possible just
keeping the bishop so very interesting
yeah I really wasn't sure if maybe the
endgame is a safer way because here I
don't even know funny yeah you have to
stay here spend some time calculating
this position it's good good exercise
but maybe you can trade and he won't
take take maybe rook takes whatever I
mean if rook d5 he will take 93 yeah the
question is do you want the rooks on the
board or not that's that's something you
have to to figure out them well yeah
after nature it doesn't look that bad
maybe you could still go for each 554
here now that no Queens are in the book
trying to go for a three I should still
be slightly there but it's definitely
what after after 92 just seems like
white is just going to be struggling and
you just win this beautiful with this
beautiful tactic and when he is Queen
and after that is there any more chance
that white had and uh no not when he
gives up the Queen but I thought he
would have tried Queen D 3 instead of
9091 subsidized right Queen D 3 roof you
to Kings somewhere yeah h1 but ah the
prime of king h1 was I can take on f3
here
okay quit after rook c2 so don't take my
rook yeah sure and then now simply 95 in
looks looks a very dangerous for white
discovery everything's kind of hanging
do you fall so that's why you probably
have to go to f1 but should be
completely lost after Queen c6 among
other things I'm mourning to bring in
more pieces yeah I like resistance very
much room she ate everything this King
is just out in the open doesn't seem
like all right and then yeah after that
I think after you win the Queen is just
game over pretty much right so how do
you feel in this moment about your
chances to to try to win the tournament
oh yeah I'm definitely pleased of course
with this results very important I guess
and tomorrow I'll have white against the
bar who but very beautiful comeback
thanks for sharing your thoughts on how
you know you should try to take to enjoy
the game of chess even if you lose just
learn from it and move forward because
you're gonna lose anyway sometimes but
you have to take the learning experience
and yeah alright thank you so much for
joining us today and good luck in the
next two rounds thank you alright so we
have had a very nice interview with
Jeffrey what a beautiful game and so
complicated I think and we have on the
screen vertically underway playing
against or pairing and I'm going to pull
up that game right now var has an extra
pawn in a rockin game these usually
you're taught that this routine games
should be draws but what do we have here
that's different than in those out
games that you're told that they should
be a draw the fact that black has this
pawn pushed in f5 Caleb just joined me
right back yes and we have this f5 pawn
pushed and virtually told you should
keep the pawns f7g 6 H 5 to make it very
difficult for white right to try to
improve the position but here the
question is is that move going to give
white some chances to win I think yes
yes alright you're gonna say no living
chess is a draw but so what's the
winning plan for it for white then you
try to invade but they can use the
coupons do you push well the thing is
because that pawn is pushed
why does not need to trade all of their
pawns that's the difference so now so if
you put the King on g5 you you win
basically if you do of course black
might try to get the rook and just
checkmate you there if possible of
course it's not going to be easy to do
that but I think what you you what you
have to try to do in my opinion is try
to get your king all the way to f4 then
maybe do f 3e for create a passport and
try to you know just push it a little
bit right king g5 afterwards try to get
the g6 pawn if you can okay it is to try
to trade at least little amounts of
pawns as possible bathroom should still
be a draw but I think white right has
more more chances then when the pawn is
in in f7 so if you're defending with
black here I guess you just put your
rook on the fourth-ranked to try and
need to prevent this can get four idea
for as long as possible but then I guess
white might try like rook d4 for example
well yes so you cannot really hold on to
that fourth-ranked if white wants to
prepare to play if or it's in their
territory they should be able to do it
right they put the hook in d4 like you
say or as you move your look maybe to a7
trying to get it on fourth rank then
we'll put our look in before get our
King to have four you know it doesn't
matter the rook I think doesn't need to
stay in beast on the sixth rank
all the time but we certainly have a lot
of better improvement ideas than if the
pawn were to be in f7 so yeah that
remains to be seen how this game will
plane plan out but I know for sure after
having had a tough tournament var is not
going to let this go he's going to try
his best to get as much as possible from
the position and we should expect a long
game yeah we'll see what Varga can pull
off here in his game against gray
oprah's I feel like we should check in
on our leaders game in the a group we're
not Jim abaya
against Sam Sabean looks to be a pretty
interesting position actually whoa yeah
uh-huh
like has more rooks White has more
nights yeah but what's going on oh is it
a really key d5 square and blacks King
side has been kind of shattered so a
definite compensation for a not here
that's true I mean this night could you
know have that outpost I mean and c6 is
not so easy to play for black because if
they do then they weaken their d6 pawn
of course
lose it on the spot black does have a
lot of weaknesses in this position so 95
seems like a very serious threat
actually let's go back alright so this
is what happened so white just left that
rook there I mean yeah it's been it's
been a while I mean it was a really long
thoughts line probably so this is nice
except for I think is one white
committed to this idea probably and now
they did they did not go for this pawn
in a 4 but they chose to give up the
world they cannot get the 9th ascending
so they decided to go for this idea
messing up blacks bone structure and
then Bishop g4 and it seems like why it
was okay to sacrifice the exchange uh
yeah I think this is a very sound
exchange sacrifice and white has a lot
of a lot of compensation I think Justin
white has actually drawn his game
against Sergei Ehrenberg here in the B
group and we haven't heard from Sergei
yes yeah sure that would be that would
be good I mean we should try to get
every every one of these players I'm
sure they have fans watching their games
arrive maybe following us hopefully and
so it would be nice to try to hear from
as many of these players as possible and
it looks like this is the final position
here just a night end game
no path in for either king and they
agreed on a drum yeah we haven't really
looked at this game so if we're going to
get Sergei here maybe we can ask his
thoughts about the key moments yeah
first of the game and yeah anything else
interesting in your opinion we should go
for maybe we should actually check in on
the game between Emilio Cordova and Al
Shean yeah we have no look at that game
it looks as though more end games today
and once attacking games but we also
want some in games you can learn from
both that's that's where some of these
players are really truly more skilled
than some of those those other like
international masters for example I
think the end game progress is a huge
difference between these these you know
2600 level grandmasters and even 2500
level masters that's that's for sure
and we have our look at night to end
game
why to just reach to move 40 so yeah
what'll be be taking this time from here
on out and it all Shawn actually has a
decision to make right there's some
pressure against this e5 pawn d4 is
hanging but probably that's that's done
ya know you don't really want to do that
you're going to destroy your pawns
unfortunately and then this Knight comes
in and would be kind of unpleasant in my
opinion but no he's on the move 14 right
so here's five minutes left I think we
should tell our viewers it's important
if you want if you're going to play a
game and you're reaching move 40 like
really that's your last move and you
still have time on the clock and you
feel that it's an important moment don't
let don't play the move instantaneously
make sure you spend as much of your time
as possible right don't lose on time god
forbid you're like it's like you have 35
minutes right all you have to do is make
one final decision and you can spend up
to your last seconds yeah that decision
yeah you should definitely do that
and and try to make sure you get the
best best possible move that you find
and don't let yourself be press too much
with the time like don't keep looking at
it oh my god I'm going down in time no
yes straight you spend all your time
thinking about your time yeah you do you
basically didn't do anything so you need
to make sure it looks like else I might
actually be under a little bit of
pressure here those for sure some
pressure you really want to blinking a
five but your knight is hanging and you
want to improve your knight there's some
struggle to coordinate the black pieces
you know that the knight is tied to the
e pawn the King is tied to the night so
it's almost like nothing can really move
that made me think that maybe rookie six
might might be a move for black just
simply trying to over protect this pawn
so that we can move our Knight we can go
to h6 we can go to f5 and start
attacking some of these these white
weaknesses
the only thing I would not like about
that move is the fact that you're
staying on this Fork of course if you're
not course signing you ever taken before
it doesn't matter but you should try to
keep your pieces a little bit you know
not on on tactical patterns also maybe
d5 is upon that we actually should take
care of not a five but I might be wrong
yeah so so I was Rick Ricky six I wasn't
sure how you're going to attack my ID
five maybe rook c5 or something maybe
it'll do seven with 57 then I think
ninety six is is a good move I just want
to bring this Knight to f5 and if you
start taking my pawns I can I can start
capturing some of yours interesting
interesting idea
you know course always as the defender
the more pawns that get taken off the
board that the closer to a draw you are
actually what do you think about this
move yeah this one kind of caught my eye
but I thought efore should be possible
if I thought five I can I can take it
I'm not getting for that
I hope yeah and my night is hanging but
maybe this is this is a problem
yeah I guess I might be losing losing
some material here
yeah don't think the rock belongs to the
room should go to e6 probably here how
can I improve my night then oh that's my
question
it doesn't seem to you're such an easy
such a music tusk
maybe you just let it there for sometime
maybe try to go for hmm not sure is this
particular position you can just just
sit on it's a question but you know
always as when you're defending it
you're tempted to find some active way
to play right even if it means giving up
some pollen or something you want your
pieces to be active and right now or
else Shona although all these pieces are
defending you know this nights on f7
this Kings defending the knight the
Knights defending the pawn and she has
actually gone before she takes d4 very
interesting idea so he does take his
deep on allows this Knight f4 check if
white so desires but at least now maybe
his pieces are a little bit more free to
move
well now what does she planted isn't
okay so that happened and I have for
second king of I overplayed very quickly
I'm not getting to refresh on that game
for some reason okay put it on the board
and now White has a choice he can take
an H pawn he can take a deep on but he
can take a night but I don't think that
was that one's good yeah I don't think
that no one is good so I think
regardless of what black ones are so if
white takes on d5 both the black rook
and the Black Knight are hanging so I'll
Shawn his problems to solve there maybe
rook to route to d6 okay rook d6 I could
give a check if I wanted I
I think I do want to hopefully 97 check
now I need to find a good place for the
King that probably would go just back
yeah my night is protected I'm kind of
circling with my night but but maybe
night g6o right back you know again um
I think blacks should be okay with the
draw in this position I definitely agree
feels like you know every everything is
loose for black it's a little bit loose
that's where tactic start to start to
appear yeah you have to be very care of
those pieces you have to be careful when
they're nights on the board that's
that's for sure so in fact actually I'm
sorry in that line we just looked at so
19 556 97 King e6 is is there
I want a knight c8 but I don't think I
think rook d7 is it's okay yeah I want
to go for the trade trade I'm happy with
the trade you know we thank seem to be
holding together in fellowship you know
where the King gets gets to be on a
better placement in e6 yeah if you go to
taking h5 down then your knight will not
be staying so great and I think finally
95 would be a very desirable move I
think so yeah he has to be careful to
just start trading some some pawns make
sure it doesn't leave that h-bond go too
far but if black is the 1985 then they
get to play d3 trading some pawns and
should be should be going for so good
for us good holding chances notion I
think but we do have some very important
developments and our key matchup of the
day in the B group Federico of Perez
Ponza might just be winning against tier
on her hmm so I thought black was
getting better in that position so this
was the moment that we lost so the game
and that was going three were expecting
Queens but expecting that but but I
didn't think that um it's kind of crazy
that things might have gone so wrong so
quickly for black yeah I didn't think
black was so bad let me contrast this
position
the position on the board the white rook
somehow swapped places and yeah here
yeah that [ __ ] moves out of the way and
the rook gets to the seventh rank I mean
this bishop does look like a pawn but
it's doing the the job of protecting you
know the weaknesses and now getting more
active there's a very funny maneuver
there oh yeah a five and then you move
the bishop around yeah and then you want
these things but you cannot because the
knight stops yes I cannot do that and
there are really long time and I think
maybe you should stay for this game
until they reach a more forty we haven't
heard yet whether we can get certain
Ehrenberg I think unfortunately he has
left the building we keep we can but we
kept missing our players that's not good
no worries there he was reaching he was
reaching he's just 40 seconds left on
his clock actually this is his second to
last move to make before move 40 and e
six is on the board for for white this
looks quite dangerous alright they
actually made a few more most room here
is this an e6
well this is really nice so we saw this
idea in Jeffrey's game yesterday yeah
where you know you open up a bishops
diagonal using e6 in this case there's
no light squared bishop putting pressure
but but the dark squared bishop is now
going to be a very active piece from the
centralized e4 square mm-hmm there's
stuff I mean you kind of have to take
that pawn if you're not going to take it
we're going to see a queen on the board
you didn't take it you did not take it
what oh my goodness f6 Oh daring white
to play so then he goes here and
exacting upon but mmm I don't believe in
f6 I cannot believe this move is good
for black what if I play agent what if I
just take what if you just take mm-hmm
doesn't work you take here yes it would
have been beautiful
no just take and then goodbye trying to
reveal the the rook but now
that would be a blunder I think h4
actually might be quite problematic for
black
the idea being I want to check your King
away from f7 and only then I will push
and maybe take or push ya wanted to do
don't know if you maybe not time to take
on e3 because now we go for Bishop f6
tell me we're going for Bishop f6 at
some point there's a double check there
is but where did you give it f5 or f1 ah
okay so Federico a very mature player
moves this king out of the way defends
his point all right that makes more
sense
why white gets into all this trouble
just cuz it's fun doesn't mean you
should do it yeah and they're about to
reach to move 40 black needs to make one
more move in 16 seconds so I think
that's h4 h5 idea though isn't going
going away it's not if this king is
forced away from that f7 square e 7 will
win the game so black gives one last
check with just 2 seconds on his clock
actually and makes the time control up
up to half an hour plenty of time to
think about how things could have gone
wrong it's going to be tough this one
would be very good for Federico and
we're actually do you think the mistake
was hmm I mean look at these these
pieces they got stuck from the other
side of the board yeah serving before
was such a nice idea let's go back after
if takes c3 I did not believe this is
kind of the problem with Knights in the
endgame right c4 in the middle game
great square for a knight it controls a
ton of key key squares but in this
endgame shirt it's putting pressure on a
couple of white spots but this Bishop
from d4 defends the pawns attacks the
King even looks at the Queen side as
well this is why bishops especially with
both sides on the board are very
powerful in the endgame that that is
true yeah especially if you cannot
create some concert play for yourself
like a passport or something then you're
doing you're going to have a tough time
here 92 attacking the rook rook d5 and
then yeah a maneuver just comes very
naturally came to f2
hmm not sure about this check maybe
black was overly confident about their
chances of improving Garrick and
complete and Misty idea v6 I would think
the e6 square is actually a great place
for the black rook so maybe simply
Knight c4 here well for the black no no
you mean for the King maybe for the king
okay you can get it but it's so hard
it's so hard to get it there I was just
imagining if the if the game had
continued so if this had to continued
similar to the game we're black plays
Knight c4 white plays Bishop c5 I
thought rookie six here might might put
someone uncomfortable pressure on that a
five policy all right play Bishop d4 I
might bring my king actually all the way
up to f5 if I'm allowed
oh yeah I know what you want maybe I'll
start with the g5 affection or geez
maybe mimicking h7 King gauge so yeah
and then yeah if I try to stop you then
you still go there didn't each five and
you try to you know bring the King put
more pressure and try to get to e4 yeah
baby that's a nice idea of course though
always very tempting to just get active
ETS but so a black tried to do but his
pieces actually end up kind of blocked
out of the game that's the thing because
you have to make sure that there's some
weaknesses you can attack if you if your
opponent has any way to create some
fortress and then your pieces will be
stuck of course well you have to bend
then you get what happens in the game
and we have a few more moves I think
after do to check white went to e1 and
yeah John has more decisions to make now
what to do about this h4 h5 idea and I'm
sure white actually has other other
ideas as well that that would be very
very threatening of course this is
Bishop f6 Bishop f6 is very annoying for
sure I mean in fact if we just imagine
what it's tough to pastor black so I we
can't really imagine but Bishop sauce
I wonder is that even if I thought I
could take anything oh yeah yeah and now
if you take a five oh just going too low
but yeah if you take if I take your rook
but if you leave then mm-hm
maybe simply Bishop c5 is creating some
trying to go 7 and then repair and then
promote it's for sure a very too many
options way too many
so so this one looking like a win for
for Federico we think of course this
means with a win in this game Federico
will be joining Sergei Ezra and Alexei
Sorokin at the top of the leaderboard
four and a half out of seven is is
enough to tie for first two right now in
the Winter Classic I'm sure in these
paths in these last two rounds
somebody's gonna pull away the way or or
we might have some matches play our
slaves to be very very interesting
indeed well see that remains to be seen
for the moment it's let's go back to a
var against apparent and see how things
have changed in that game alright so
last time I stopped we it was they had
just entered that four versus three
rookin game and var was able to get to
their I progressed the moves that I told
you get the King to f4 prepare for 84 he
didn't get to play it yet but there will
be seven very nice last move by my white
kind of keeping black in some kind of a
super nearly conversations rack f2 and
this F to score in the f1 square for
this rug yeah that's that's what black
should do actually this is this is the
best defense mechanism nothing reason
why is you were explaining White's ideas
efore right yes and you really want to
capture back on e4 with your pawn not
not using not the kingdom the reason for
that is you make a passed pawn so with
this work on f1 of course taking back
that way is illegal
yeah so is there any way for white to
force this rook off of this
while it actually looks kind of
difficult to achieve well I think so far
actually played rock f7 so the idea is
probably after rook F 2 maybe we want to
go for some chief I'm not sure if it
works
G 4 I think H takes
why he put Duncan f7 I do not know I
guess he wants to be enough to yeah
maybe he's just working some time
not every move has to be it you know but
let's try to find let's try to see if
there's some winning idea right I don't
I felt G for we're supposed to be so
similar to here's an idea
what if I put my rook on the first drink
so I'll play it like Rick a seven for
example you can play your a tough one
and I'll play let's say rook F - it
doesn't really work a - it doesn't
really matter
well that's what I thought in the first
place but he went to have seven I think
maybe he's worried that the scheme could
go back
so yeah King g7 and then I guess the
meta good thing to calculate his King g5
this was my idea and unfortunately I
think I'm just giving up way too many
pawns it is there's not enough time to
really try to checkmate black there I
think it's it's just just a draw but if
white doesn't go for this idea I don't
think there's much else well there is
there is there is there is amazing idea
I don't know even what yes somehow it
would be with that with that line we we
just looked at right know with the
reckoning shades but I don't know how I
can get it how is that ever confused I
get my kingdom sticks that's more
ridiculous than my no no I I'm trying
and trying to find some some improvement
so and we do do see it'll have two on
the board one and it takes some time but
he's uh serve ours is gonna try to win
this game for a long time there's
actually only one other game still going
on in the a group but it's a very very
important game for our standings that is
we're not Jim abaya against Sam Savion
of course
this is where white plate was super
interesting exchange sacrifice and tried
to play against the black King and
blacks weaknesses and black did give it
back it was like let's see how that
happened let's move a few let's go a few
moves back I believe we were kind of
stuck around
maybe after Knight 94 we're good at
Knightly five options yeah yeah
so it takes Queen takes rook e5 rookie
five all right so now we're so ninety
five typical we expected that the knight
will be placed in d5 that sense right
placement for it so now black is trying
to regroup a little bit and bring their
Queen to start protecting some of these
weaknesses you cannot afford to lose
them all so right now after Knight takes
that for White has one point for the
exchange but but now we see Bishop c6
putting pressure in a floor white pawns
are all really really mobile on the
Kings side and this is yeah like f4
we're trying now for f4 and this move is
very interesting because now you cannot
capture any four because we are looking
at rates so I guess black decided enough
was enough
enough was enough no more nights going
night and now let's try to play this
position um what looks like something
for for Rinat here we do have a pawn
down for black but now Queen g5 is going
to try to get the palm back but I think
most importantly for black is to try to
put pressure on the G file and on this
King and make sure that your king
they're only blacks is going to stay
safe of course easier said than done
right both Kings kind of in some open
and open positions here so Rho K 1 f5
rook G 1 now we're threatening some
discoveries so be ready for that Queen
f4 check first making sure to escape it
the Queen first and now Sam is not so
worried about the discovery because the
bishop doesn't really have that good of
a placement for it so Ruki 5 making sure
White's Queen will be closed from the
dash
to make sure the rookin queen cannot be
combined and cooperate so now we see
Rinat improving the position of his
queen on the other side trying to go
through oh well Queen eight seven
through the other side okay I like that
idea actually all right oh and they did
repeat the position twice technically
right I mean this position rice
it appeared twice yeah and I think Queen
d7 has been played Sam is currently
thinking should I take the draw or not
in this position I would be hard-pressed
to play on here no we're not which is
like pieces okay with white I think you
have a few options the King doesn't your
King and h1 does look a little unsafe
but you have this rook you have this
bishop and if if I can try and channel
my Yassir yeah a3 singing yeah but f2
it's also yes so I'm not sure you wanna
you wanna take that pawn for the f2 1 f2
is way too close to the king maybe I'll
take I'll take f5 maybe this is a little
less less absurd than the new queen a3
it's kind of interesting here too
psychologically what are the players
thinking and well and if we will still
be live don't be nice to actually get
one of them of course and I actually am
quite curious what happens after rook e8
he takes that five because that looks
kind of strong for white
of course now the the Bishop discoveries
have become a little bit more potent and
if you take on g2 I can I can take back
with a check where to move the king that
is the question well you're thinking of
that I'll think of what I'm doing with
the way because this because this is if
you need to be mess well you can't go
for this Queen a5 maybe we need five
controlling e1 sounds like a good idea
defending f5 then by a pure chance
maybe you can just try to get a ch3 and
a c7 oh you take your check
so maybe eight but then if you go to H
it then when C 3 is always going to be a
threat
yeah what's risky for a hurry now let's
think let's think about this position
for a little bit longer so taking that 5
I think Bishop takes G 2 must must be
correct should be unmeaning
unless I want to just move the king
somewhere and let you take that and then
I have Queen f3 check but then well I
think the G 1 is actually better square
for my bishop than a our G 1 is the
better square for my rook than G 2
because this is first strengths weakness
isn't isn't going to be there maybe I go
Keeney f8 what do you think about this
one
yeah I think this might actually be the
best square I think I still have to try
Queen a5 I don't see any of you any
other move for white yeah but at least
now you're not taking c7 I was checked
so I can try to think of my attacking
AT&T between everybody might be working
and now you have to be careful you
cannot really move this Queen a5 was
very late Queen d2 maybe you take h3 I
go to g1 I have a lot of threats oh wait
hahaha lot of nasty threat mmm very
unpleasant hmm maybe I can escape maybe
not this queen is getting a lot of
mileage going to a5 it is very
interesting to come back with the Queen
just know this this looks very tough for
Sam if you're not used to playing on
is there anything else that black can do
here instead of roki eight maybe just
not going back and saying I don't think
you actually have that much well the
problem for black is always where the
King Israel to be King F F file f7 f8
but the promise cream b8 grew me a check
or not check and then that pawn is going
to be hanging with a check so it's going
to be kind of unpleasant
well okay looks like hang f7 if you play
Queen b8 I might be taking on e4 maybe
and then after I take you forward you
can take c7 with Chuck but I'll have oh
I want to take with the bishop I'm sorry
I want to pressure your King and then
you have rookie 7 yeah Ricky 72 block
the check and then you're actually
losing a temple for the Queen c7 usually
with check you gain a tempo but with
with the the counter threat to the Queen
white would actually run out of no not a
moves there that is becoming this is a
tough decision to make with with black
here because the doughnuts why same is
this thinking so long yeah and you you
sometimes don't know because I have seen
a lot of grandmasters you know repeating
the position twice pretending like that
I actually want to draw well they're
waiting for you to spend all your time
and then they don't want to draw I don't
wanna mention now you see on the board
we're not actually has 26 minutes left
and Sam has just over 22 minutes but
this is move 41 they never reported you
they just hit time control so they were
likely repeating to get that extra
half-hour at it on and now Rinat has
thought for a few minutes and he's gone
for Queen a7 and I think he's decided on
what he wants to do so no Sam taking his
time making sure he finds the absolute
best offense that's for sure it's going
to be a tough game we do still have a
few games left so it's just this game
with me not and then var pressing that 4
versus 3 endgame so he actually did come
back on the second right okay
he went 447 King g7 good now it'll be
interesting to see if he actually goes
he goes not go for King g5 he just moves
44 and so I think this is much closer to
a draw now than the four versus three it
is no black has to improve the position
of the rook I think you should not stay
there anymore yes so we take King takes
and now I'm anticipating something like
maybe rook e1 check and get into
Brooklyn and maybe just okay one and so
interestingly so these are the only two
games going on in the a group
we're expecting regard to be able to
hold that position and we're expecting
I'm expecting at least I think we're not
the fighting player he's not missed any
chances really this tournament I'm
expecting him to try and win that
against same seven and in the B group
interestingly since the last time we
checked in only one move has been played
in either game yeah so these players
really taking their time use this this
was the game between em you know Cordova
and Elgin Mirada body and we see King g3
that was the move that we have not
considered previously not taking either
hanging pot just
yeah and now okay those two points are
still hanging but so is the night
there's some funny business 95 Rick h7
mix-up direct right oh yeah that's
that's not going to be a very fun very
fun idea
yeah so threatening of course you're at
age five with checkmate so that's why I
don't believe you can improve a you can
do anything about that so let's yeah so
night 95 is not going to work no
interesting that we thought f5 was a big
improvement for the king but it's got
kind of trapped in the center of the
board and that's why I guess white left
this night on f4 making sure that these
these threats against the king could
could remain with east six and g6 both
being covered
I wonder if rugby eight is a good move
in this position ah so the idea is of
course what do you play Newark up 7 just
check and then King f2 and then we take
take the pawn animated the rook takes
your F pawn but it's it's a different
kind of three versus three little bit
difficult but I think
and relax should be able to hold this
but maybe even have some other options
after kingi three um yeah I'm not sure
if you move this night wreckage seven is
going to come well for sure you
shouldn't move it in e5 so yeah well you
have to leave as you go to like c6
though Rick age seven yeah five is my
only move and h5 Falls
I think if h5 is falling you'd rather
have the Knights off the board than on
the board I'm glad it's true so you have
to find the right place to trade the
Knights so I think I don't think there's
any way we're saving this h5 point slide
but black currently has an extra point
on the door so you know but even got
airborne it's yeah I think then your
idea with rupee eight is probably the
best way to give it up you just go for
the pure up endgame your D pawns are
pretty far advanced actually so things
like d3 are going to kind of shake loose
the white structure and I think this
this might be hold a ball this should be
but still like you need to it's not
going to be so easy like yeah why to
stay with F and H bones and then you'll
have the deep on the question is should
you try to keep that pawn or give it up
because you know fnh you should be able
to make a drop but you should yeah it's
not an easy one but this might be a very
long game so it's it's a game to to
watch out for for sure yeah and then in
our game against Federico poncy and
Tigran hurt Union so I guess it's not
moved
yeah and around 25 minutes I think 20
minutes and black still deep in thought
here you probably realizes it's it's a
very bad position to losing if not
completely lost so we do not really see
any ways for black to be able to stop
this very annoying pawn right there are
a lot of ways for white to try to
improve h4 h5 as we discussed previously
Bishop c5 as well it's it's all Bishop
c5 push the pawn go with the rook on the
edge and support the poem from promoting
so those are just a few of White's ideas
and with the rook on d2 completely
restricted by White's very strong bishop
in d4 it's going to be very tough for
black to find something to come into the
game so I think we're going to
anticipate the win for for white in this
position well as these games are
wrapping up why don't we take a look and
see where we stand both in the a group
in the B group C the a group standings
first you're not in Juma buy of of
course his game is still going it seems
as though and the lines but we were
looking at it he might actually have
some pressure against Sam 7 so we're
expecting me not to not lose this game
but definitely all three results are
possible in that game for sure yes
Jeffrey Jean managed to win today
bringing his score back up to four and a
half so for the moment he's tied with me
not but of course we expect me not to be
able to score some number of points
either a half point or one point Jane
Milner did ski drew quite early on today
and Sam 7 still in in progress against
Rina isaku has drawn against Daniel
Gregorio Oberyn is trying to hold a four
versus three rock end game against Varro
Cobian and for the moment it seems as
though he's going to be able to hold
that victory Erdos lost his game today
to Jeffrey and Alexi Serena managed to
defeat defeat Havana's Kabu Xion and so
they go to three and two and a half
respectively why don't we check out the
B group standings as well
Sergei azeroth in Alexi Sorokin the two
leaders going into today have actually
drawn each other so their score moves to
four and a half out of seven as well
Melik option also drew his game and be
on the lookout because we expect
federico perez Ponza to be able to win
his game against Tigran our union and he
will move to four and a half out of
seven as well
joining the leaders and in the game
between Emilio Cordova and El Shawn
maratti a body
we're expecting a draw hoping for a draw
maybe for dry
emilio does seem to have some kind of
some kind of edge in that endgame some
tricky some tactical tricks still yeah
in the position definitely look for that
position to clarify actually the next
few moves don't be slow moves both I'm
sure taking a lot of time but it looks
like clarity some clarifying yeah but
not that much time because now they are
they're spent quite some time after the
time control and we are going to
approach some more blitzing I think
that's beyond the looking
Justin Wang has drawn his game against
Sergei Ehrenberg and Chris Hume has also
drawn today and that is where we stand
after seven rounds in the winter chess
classic what's a de Cadenet definitely a
day of excitement a day of very
interesting games Jeffrey's young kind
of just demolished his opponent and it
was an interesting interview to see him
explain that game as well well thank you
guys very much for joining us here today
as always if you want to follow the
games for yourself you can still see the
games that are in progress at u.s. chess
chance calm tomorrow we will be on at
our normal time 3:30 p.m. but be on the
lookout for Monday when we'll be
starting a couple hours earlier any
closing thoughts on today's around
Savina uh well I'm just really looking
for for the last two two games I think
everyone everyone is trying their best
trying to catch up with the leaders or
staying in a leading position but
everyone has done a really yeah
95 I cannot believe that oh my goodness
95 was played and Wow so at the very end
of our show here Emilio Cordova does win
his game against all Shawn else I'm
falling into that that meeting trap that
we actually talked about unfortunate
there for El Shawn but ok that'll be the
end of our show I think so thank you
guys very much for joining us as always
be sure to tune in tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
for more live coverage of the winter
chess classic
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you